[Music]
okay so Jimbo you know that I like wwa
to k17 I do know that well I've been
playing around with it and I've
discovered something I got bored with
these little end intros those little
introductions to each player where they
come down to the ring because it's
identical every single time so for
example Brock Lesnar tell me what what
you see what does Brock Lesnar do on the
typical entrance same thing every single
time walking that wall right now I'm
looking at him working down really
slowly jump up on the apron set up a
nice little bit of pyro and act like a
piece okay so I reimagine this I thought
what would it look like if Brock Lesnar
while the attire of Paul Heyman and Paul
Heyman came out looking more like Brock
Lesnar they don't really make sense that
big just like a manager yes the lead is
student everywhere
look how cocky you look so great and
look now extending the middle of the
ring is more appalling than I ever
wanted to see I didn't think he'd be
clean-shaven on the chest
okay so let's switch this up a bit I got
a bit cocky but first let's just see
that a typical introduction for Samoa
jaw so Jimbo tell me what Samoa Joe's
entrance is usually like I mean this is
it there's nothing more to it this is
the
is just a no-frills entrance isn't it
yeah really mean face as well he means
business
yeah waddling down to the ring so yes I
mojo to me is far
black to be slimming look at the Jo that
that t-shirt is a bit too tight on you
so no more grumpy Jo he's now a really
positive face it gets quite so here we
go the next one it's still he still
brought Lesnar but this time I thought
so I like how he gets in the ring I
think this is hilarious now is that we
really should get now the Brock Lesnar's
camping it up he looks shinier look at
this not a sex on a stick for that that
really really suits him showing off
showing up that cleavage he's been
working on for years you can handle this
I'm Brock Lesnar you don't want none of
this okay so back to jaw
well jaw has always loved a bit of
Mexican wrestling so this time Samoa Joe
this decides is gonna come
completely defying gravity really ah
this is like when those wrestlers just
you know wear masks and hide in the
crowd to disguise of so except here we
all know it's no get away with the ha
okay right so next we're going to the
Wyatt family this is slow methodical
creepy really as slow as possibly how's
that light doesn't need to sort and make
it look hot ominous and then all the
crowd has cameras right yeah you were
right the crowd with their lighters in
their light their phone lights I believe
they're known as the fireflies or
something along those lines
well again he's a bit too serious for me
so he needs he needs to come down with
the new Wyatt family prefer to have fun
gone are the days of dark night it's all
about lots of energy lots of fun
everyone's here to have a good time with
the Wyatt family and Husky Harris is
back why is he going Towell I don't get
that I'm trying to figure out whose
entrance this actually is and I've got
no idea
come on oh it's because the music hasn't
changed I kept from the original Wyatt
family music is about the new day is it
new day oh okay
it is yeah yeah but only as a tag team I
thought it looked better ice for a
second I always thinking is it too cool
next okay so we're on to the last ones
now so the Brothers of Destruction so
that's the Undertaker and Kane now
depending on your viewpoint this is
either the greatest entrance in the
history of pro wrestling or the most
boring I think this this this kind of
splits fans opinions because look at it
well his brother is Ken and he's from
hell if he didn't know already his
gimmick is nothing but fire isn't it
fire in brinster yeah
I think we were meant to believe if he
wore a mask to cover the burns caused in
the house fire that killed their parents
that's pretty good entrance but when
they're together as the Brothers of
Destruction their entrance could be
improved look at them working it the
sisters of destruction from now on I'm
sure that rope would take different than
usual but I hope you liked it anywhere
James thank you for your time fella
we'll be back to normal playing next
week so please like and subscribe we
really need your help thank you very
much I'm Adam from Playstation grenades
in this guy's James games